And now I want to know that this time, I now have 1 hour and 21 minutes, and I am observing John's fireflies,
lifting away from me.
I'm going to observe him.
He's going to be departing from the spacecraft and drifting out to the rear.
I'm going to see some of them.
He's going to set a more distance out to the rear.
He's going up behind me.
I'm going to get the glow on the cloud.
Fireflies appear to be white.
Very whitish with almost a green light rail fireflies.
Clouds on the Earth are changing color.
They are getting quite light.
I'm going to see some of them.
I have been on the daytime, decided not yet quite up, and I am observing stars.
The Earth is light for lonely.
John is still behind me.
This guy looks dark above me, and I can see stars.
Very distinctly.